can we talk about tokens a little bit
generally speaking there's been a
meteoric rise of a bunch of different
tokens we could just talk about bitcoin
and ethereum as examples
bitcoin i think cost 60 000 in value
what are your thoughts in general on
this rise what's the future of bitcoin
what's the future of ethereum
uh there's there's the total value
locked metric
that i think generalizes the different
kind of value of these
uh of these tokens
what does the future value
and impact of cryptocurrency look like
if we look through the lens of these
tokens
i think valuing all these tokens and
determining that isn't something i'm
particularly great at i haven't spent a
lot of time on that
i've spent the majority vast majority of
my time on building these systems
and architecting them and getting them
to fruition and getting them to a place
where they operate properly
on both the technical and the crypto
economic and every other and in every
other sense
i i think with bitcoin there is um
a certain conception of non-governmental
fiat money
that bitcoin is really the first uh
creator of
right so there's this very powerful idea
called fiat money
it's basically um more or less a kind of
40-year experiment
i think on august 15th of this year is
is maybe i think even the 40th
anniversary
you know government can say hey i have a
currency and it's worth something
and and here it is in terms of
the way that governments have stopped
that in the past is if anyone tries to
make another fiat currency in their
country
they immediately shut it down right they
immediately say hey
this is really bad you've done something
really bad it's time for you to stop
don't do it anymore and it stops right
that's been the history of
non-governmental fiat currency bitcoin
is really due to its decentralized
nature
the first um and possibly in some cases
in many people's minds it's still the
only
true non-governmental fiat currency
now how powerful is non-governmental
fiat currency
i have no idea right this is why so
it's really as powerful as the ideas
that people
ascribe to it are right so let's say
people start saying like right now
people are saying hey it's internet
money
it's the money of the internet okay
great what's that worth i don't know
it's probably worth a lot i have no idea
what it's worth
but it's worth as an idea as a concept
to underpin
the fiat money the let there be aspect
of of of of fiat and of bitcoin
you basically look at it and you say
yeah internet money
okay that could be worth whatever you
know sixty thousand six hundred thousand
great question right there are other
versions of the world right where people
say
you know um there are countries that
don't have a good fiat
currency and i see a lot of people using
bitcoin
so bitcoin isn't internet money it's
um countries without a good currency
money
so all the countries without a good
currency not now use uh bitcoin
and you know let there be bitcoin as
this right as this conception of bitcoin
what's the value of that
i don't know that's a great question
probably probably huge amount of value
um then there's then there's a further
conception of
bitcoin has some you know digital gold
there's a scarcity dynamic
there's there's all these other kinds of
dynamics what is
a portable version of digital gold with
some kind of built-in
um built in
scarcity worth you know kind of
artificially created
scarcity um what's that worth
i don't know that's that's a great
question i i haven't done the analysis
on that is the point
might be worth a lot what is it all
worth if all three of these things
you know flow into the same fiat um kind
of
let there be bitcoin as these three
things conception of bitcoin
i don't know what that's worth i also
don't know what that's worth but it
could be worth a huge amount
so i i think it's it's not i don't think
it's i personally don't think it's super
important what i think it's worth
or what many other people think it's
worth i don't think that's that's really
that important
i think what's probably important is
understanding
what the societal conception of bitcoin
is and how does that societal conception
evolve over time and that
interestingly enough doesn't just depend
on um
you know you or me or the people who
made bitcoin or anything else
it actually depends on current events so
for example if people suddenly say
i i'm more and more worried about fiat
currency
i'm more and more worried that
governmental fiat
even if it's the most reliable version
of that
is not as good as i thought it was maybe
i should go on the paypal app and maybe
i should get some bitcoin
just in case what's the world
where bitcoin is a certain percentage of
everyone's ownership
as a hedge against governmental fiat
money
not being so good having done the
analysis but another example right
here's this conception
that's that's the conception so when i
look at bitcoin
what i see is a lot of these fascinating
conceptions
of of what the fiat let there be value
of bitcoin is
by the way all of them could be true um
maybe some of them are true maybe some
of them aren't true and and the
fascinating thing is is that i've seen
this conception change right so when i
started
in the bitcoin space the conception was
micropayments
the the the cost of bitcoin is low we'll
have micro payments
micro payments are wonderful for uh
machine to machine
uh transactions micro payments are
wonderful the emerging market
and that's fine right and and that was
one conception of bitcoin as
let there be bitcoin as micro payments
platform right
but then the value rose and things
changed there was enough expansion in
certain ways
and and now the conception has evolved
into this other conception
but but at the end of the day um i think
governments
have a very clear set of steps for
directing
the public's conception of
their fiat right they say our fiat is
worth this for these these reasons
bitcoin doesn't have that bitcoin
doesn't have an official bitcoin
spokesperson
that goes out and says the
non-governmental money called bitcoin
the non-governmental fiat money called
bitcoin
has value on the basis of this this and
this here's our fiscal budget here's our
future plans
you know our money will continue to be
safe and secure and reliable
and so it's what what that hole creates
is a hole that we all fill right we all
basically come to some vague
kind of group understanding that you
know bitcoin
is worth is worth this because it is
tied let
is it is tied to um
you know let's say
all non-governmental fiat money comes
into question everybody doubts it
uh possibly due to inflation and
everybody says you know
this is nice but i'd like to keep 10 20
of my of my wealth in non-governmental
fiat
just in case um you know
what what are those numbers i mean if
that happens
you know i'm guessing you can add a few
zeros
i like how you say i haven't done the
analysis as if i'm sure a lot of people
have done quote unquote analysis
but it's not it's still speculation
nobody can predict the future especially
when so much of it has to do with a
large number of people
holding an idea in their mind as to the
importance of a particular technology
like bitcoin
there's a lot of excitement by its
possibilities but the number of zeros
you add
is uh is an open question and nobody can
do a perfect analysis
except whoever created this simulation
you